Mon rêve,
c’est que dans quelques années
— disons peut-être
dans cinq dix ans —
vous puissiez écrire dans vos dissertations
des phrases comme :
« Romain Treffel écrit
dans son Histoire de la philosophie
que blablabla… ».
MAIS…
il faut que je fasse attention,
parce que vous ne pouvez pas mobiliser
N’IMPORTE QUELLE
référence
dans une dissertation.
Petite précision pour commencer,
pour que tout soit bien clair
dans votre esprit :
quand je parle de « référence »,
c’est dans un sens GÉNÉRAL.
Ce n’est pas obligatoirement un essai
ou un livre de fiction
— ça peut être un article,
un discours,
un poème,
une œuvre d’art,
etc.
Une « référence »,
c’est un produit de la culture
qui fait AUTORITÉ,
c’est-à-dire que les sociétés estiment
qu’il faut reconnaître
LA VALEUR
de ce produit culturel,
et qu’il faut s’y soumettre.
Par exemple,
un essai philosophique
est une référence
au sens où on estime
qu’il a fait progresser la pensée ;
une peinture peut être
une référence
au sens où on estime
qu’elle nous a permis de jeter sur le monde
un regard nouveau.
Je veux aussi vous rappeler
LA FONCTION
d’une référence :
en dissertation,
une référence sert à
APPORTER DU CRÉDIT
— le crédit
d’une autorité extérieure reconnue —
une référence sert à apporter du crédit
À UN ARGUMENT.
Donc une référence ne sert pas à montrer
que vous avez appris votre cours,
que vous êtes cultivé,
ou à impressionner le correcteur :
d’accord ?
Si vous voulez vous faire valoir
auprès du correcteur,
ce n’est pas au niveau des références
que ça se passe
— ça se passe au niveau
DE LA MÉTHODOLOGIE.
Et pour ça,
j’ai ce qu’il vous faut :
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Plus de TRENTE MILLE
élèves l’ont déjà suivi,
et j’ai reçu beaucoup
d’e-mails de remerciements
— donc je n’ai aucun doute
que ça va vous plaire
à vous aussi.
Inscrivez-vous maintenant
pour ne pas oublier,
mais vous pourrez découvrir mon cours
après cette vidéo,
ou dans les prochains jours,
parce que c’est un cours par e-mail.
Là tout de suite,
concentrez-vous
pour regarder ATTENTIVEMENT
cette vidéo jusqu’au bout.
Dans dix minutes,
la sélection des références
n’aura plus de secret pour vous,
et cela vous fera gagner des points
DÈS
votre prochaine dissertation.
Est-ce que
vous avez déjà entendu parler
de la fameuse dissertation
de culture générale
sur le sujet
« Y’a t-il encore
des grands hommes ? »
— qui,
de mémoire,
a été notée dix-neuf
sur vingt
au concours d’entrée de l’ENA ?
Cette dissertation,
on me l’a montrée
quand je préparais ce concours :
je me souviens
que les élèves étaient en extase
quand ils la lisaient.
Ils étaient en extase
parce que dans cette copie,
il y a LITTÉRALEMENT
UNE RÉFÉRENCE
par phrase !
Et du coup,
les élèves qui la lisent sans réfléchir
en déduisent
qu’il faut GAVER
le correcteur
de références.
Mais ces élèves manquent
CRUELLEMENT
de pragmatisme !
Ils ne comprennent pas
que cette copie,
si brillante soit-elle,
constitue un MAUVAIS
modèle.
Eh bien oui,
parce qu’UN BON
modèle,
c’est un modèle que vous pouvez
FACILEMENT
imiter.
Vous croyez VRAIMENT
que vous allez apprendre
dix mille références
d’ici votre prochaine dissertation,
ou même
d’ici votre épreuve de concours ?
Mais surtout,
vous croyez VRAIMENT
que vous serez capable
de LES MOBILISER
dans une dissertation ?
Bien sûr que non.
Posez-vous la question :
COMMENT
certains élèves
parviennent-ils à écrire
des dissertations
que vous trouvez
ULTRA BRILLANTES,
des dissertations
BOURRÉES de références ?
En fait,
il y a deux possibilités.
La première,
c’est que l’élève ait eu
un coup de chance.
Il est super calé
sur un thème précis,
et le sujet qui tombe
porte sur ce thème !
Je connais par exemple
quelqu’un qui avait écrit un mémoire
sur l’art dans les régimes totalitaires,
et qui a passé un concours
où le sujet d’une épreuve de dissertation
était justement sur la culture
dans les régimes totalitaires
— cet étudiant n’était
pas particulièrement doué en dissertation,
MAIS LÀ
il a cartonné.
La SECONDE HYPOTHÈSE
qui explique que certains élèves
parviennent à écrire
des dissertations
que vous trouvez
ULTRA BRILLANTES,
des dissertations
BOURRÉES de références,
c’est qu’EUX-MÊMES
soient brillants.
Et j’en ai connus
des comme ça :
leurs deux parents
sont profs en prépa
ou à l’université,
ou bien ils sont diplômés
des écoles les plus prestigieuses,
et du coup les enfants
ont eu le nez dans les livres
et ont entendu des conversations brillantes
depuis leur plus jeune âge.
Là,
en termes de connaissances pures,
vous ne pouvez pas lutter.
Voici pourquoi
les copies bourrées de références
sont de MAUVAIS
modèles.
La PREMIÈRE règle
pour choisir les références,
c’est donc de faire l’inverse :
choisissez UNE SEULE
ET UNIQUE
référence par argument.
Choisissez une référence
qui est PERTINENTE
et QUE VOUS MAÎTRISEZ,
puis expliquez dans le paragraphe
en quoi elle crédibilise votre argument.
Si vous essayez
d’impressionner le correcteur
en accumulant les références,
elles seront moins pertinentes ;
vous les expliquerez moins bien ;
elles ne seront probablement pas cohérentes
les unes par rapport aux autres ;
et les transitions de l’une à l’autre
seront probablement maladroites.
La première règle
découle d’un phénomène bien connu :
très souvent,
la QUALITÉ
décroît avec la QUANTITÉ.
D’après mon expérience,
vous vous débrouillerez donc
BIEN MIEUX
en vous concentrant
sur UNE SEULE
ET UNIQUE
référence par argument.
Allez,
on passe
à la deuxième règle !
Vous imaginez,
vous,
citer une bande dessinée
dans une dissertation
de culture générale
au concours d’entrée de l’ENA ?
Honnêtement,
moi je ne prendrais pas le risque.
Mais je me souviens
qu’un de mes profs avait raconté
qu’un de ses élèves
avait décroché
SEIZE SUR VINGT
en culture générale au concours de l’ENA
avec une accroche sur…
Lucky Luke !
C’est sûr qu’avec cette accroche,
il est sorti du lot.
La référence a dû SURPRENDRE
le correcteur,
donc elle est ORIGINALE.
D’un côté,
Lucky Luke appartient bien
au patrimoine culturel
de la francophonie ;
mais de l’autre,
la bande dessinée,
c’est un support
qui apparaîtra moins NOBLE
aux yeux du correcteur.
Maintenant,
j’ai une autre anecdote
à vous raconter :
il y a quelques années,
dans la classe d’un de mes élèves,
le prof avait expliqué
qu’une copie de culture générale
pouvait se démarquer
en mobilisant des références artistiques.
Comme il avait dit ça,
certains élèves s’étaient mis
à citer EXCLUSIVEMENT
des tableaux
— quel que soit le sujet,
quel que soit l’argument,
ils citaient un tableau !
Ah,
la consigne n’était pas tombée
dans l’oreille d’un sourd !
Les élèves ne s’étaient pas posé
la question :
COMBIEN
de références originales
une bonne dissertation
doit-elle comporter ?
Alors,
par principe,
vous ne pouvez pas
mobiliser UNE MAJORITÉ
de références originales
— mais OÙ PLACER
le curseur ?
Pour faire simple,
je vous conseille
de viser une proportion de Pareto,
c’est-à-dire environ
QUATRE-VINGT POUR CENT
de références classiques,
et VINGT POUR CENT
de références originales
— c’est la DEUXIÈME RÈGLE
pour choisir les références.
Après,
c’est au doigt mouillé,
bien sûr.
Par exemple,
si vous mobilisez en tout
NEUF DIX
références
dans votre dissertation,
autorisez-vous maximum
DEUX TROIS
références originales.
Si vous ne mobilisez que six références,
autorisez-vous maximum
une ou deux références originales.
Et puis idéalement,
ne mettez pas
toutes les références originales
dans la même grande partie
— c’est mieux de les disperser.
Mais bon,
ça c’est un détail
— la réussite de votre dissertation
ne se joue pas à ça.
Et pour vous dire la vérité,
ce n’est pas CRUCIAL
que vous mobilisiez
des références originales.
Vous pouvez très bien
décrocher une bonne note
en mobilisant EXCLUSIVEMENT
des références classiques.
En revanche,
vous prenez un risque
si vous mobilisez
trop de références originales,
parce que le correcteur pensera probablement
que vous ne maîtrisez pas
les références CLASSIQUES.
Donc mon conseil c’est :
apprenez EN PRIORITÉ
des références classiques ;
ne vous prenez pas la tête
avec les références originales,
et si vous voulez en mobiliser,
souvenez-vous
qu’elles doivent être MINORITAIRES
dans la dissertation.
Après,
il y a des références
que vous devez PUREMENT
ET SIMPLEMENT
éviter !
Imaginez que vous rédigez
une dissertation sur l’amour :
est-ce que c’est une bonne idée
de citer Cinquante nuances de Grey ?
Si vous pensez que oui,
alors vous faites VRAIMENT BIEN
de regarder cette vidéo.
Eh bien non,
c’est une mauvaise idée,
parce que Cinquante nuances de Grey,
c’est une référence
VULGAIRE.
Ce n’est bien évidemment PAS
une référence classique
— je ne sais même pas
si on peut dire
que c’est une référence
ORIGINALE —
mais c’est une référence
VULGAIRE
parce qu’il est admis
qu’elle N’ÉLÈVE PAS
l’esprit humain
— ça changera peut-être avec le temps,
mais pour l’instant
Cinquante nuances de Grey
n’a pas accédé au statut
de référence
NOBLE.
Ne confondez donc pas
les références ORIGINALES
et les références VULGAIRES.
Une référence originale
peut avoir un effet « rafraîchissant »,
parce que par définition
elle va SURPRENDRE
le correcteur ;
en revanche,
une référence vulgaire vous attirera
LE MÉPRIS
du correcteur,
et peut donc vous faire perdre
beaucoup de points.
Les références vulgaires
appartiennent généralement
à la culture populaire RÉCENTE
(disons des vingt trente
dernières années).
Cinquante nuances de Grey
est par exemple un livre de 2012
et un film de 2015,
donc il est trop récent
pour figurer dans une dissertation
— mais il ne le sera peut-être plus
en 2040
ou en 2050.
En comparaison,
Lucky Luke a été créée
dans les années 1940
1950.
Il existe UNE AUTRE RAISON
de vous censurer
concernant les références :
LA CONTROVERSE.
Si vous écriviez une dissertation
au dix-septième siècle,
je vous déconseillerais
de citer des auteurs
EXPLICITEMENT ATHÉES,
ou qui remettent en question
la version de l’histoire de l’humanité
donnée par la Bible.
Je ne dis pas que Dieu n’existe pas,
ni que la Bible
est un récit mensonger
— je dis
qu’il y a plusieurs centaines d’années,
remettre en question l’existence de Dieu
ou bien le récit biblique,
cela suscitait la controverse,
au point qu’un correcteur de dissertation
condamnerait ces idées.
Eh bien,
il est raisonnable de penser
que c’est pareil à chaque époque :
certaines idées controversées,
ou politiquement incorrectes,
sont susceptibles
de heurter la sensibilité
d’une personne
que vous ne connaissez pas personnellement.
Donc si vous craignez qu’une référence
ne soit TROP CONTROVERSÉE,
abstenez-vous de la mobiliser.
Vous pouvez éventuellement
vous le permettre
à deux conditions :
si vous tirez l’analyse de la référence
controversée
d’une référence TIERCE
qui fait autorité
(par exemple,
si vous la tirez
d’un manuel d’histoire des idées politiques)
;
et,
deuxième condition,
si vous introduisez la référence controversée
AVEC TACT,
en en condamnant,
au moins implicitement,
le propos.
Oui,
je sais bien :
je vous conseille
de vous autocensurer.
Mais ce n’est pas la lâcheté
qui inspire ce conseil,
c’est LA RÉALITÉ
DES RAPPORTS HUMAINS
qui vous commande de le suivre
PAR PRAGMATISME.
Votre correcteur n’est pas prêt
À TOUT LIRE,
donc vous devez être PRUDENTS.
Je vous rappelle rapidement
les trois règles :
vous devez choisir
UNE SEULE
ET UNIQUE
référence
par argument ;
vous devez mobiliser
MAXIMUM
vingt pour cent
de références originales ;
et enfin,
vous devez ÉVITER
les références vulgaires
ou trop controversées.
MAIS encore une fois,
comme je l’ai déjà dit
dans beaucoup de vidéos,
les références NE SONT PAS
l’enjeu ESSENTIEL
de l’exercice de la dissertation.
Ce n’est pas en vous prenant la tête
avec les références
que vous progresserez en dissertation.
Pour progresser,
vous avez besoin d’une méthodologie
SOLIDE.
Donc inscrivez-vous
à mon cours gratuit de méthodologie,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Après,
même si la méthodologie,
c’est bien plus important
que la sélection des références,
j’espère comme d’habitude
que cette vidéo
vous sera UTILE.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour bien choisir vos références
en dissertation.